Speaker 1: Given what's going on in the news
today, it will be a Trump heavy program.
But we are going to start by talking about
Joe Biden, the current president.
But before I even get to that, I have to make
a really important correction on the show.
As as all of you know, if you've been around
the show for a while, I am not working with
a teleprompter.
Obama's teleprompter.
No.
I am mostly working off of general notes when
I talk.
And the other day speaking off the cuff about
Bobby Kennedy Jr's presidential candidacy,
I wrongly said I wrongly said that the Children's
Defense Fund is the anti-vaccine organization
he started.
It is not the correct organization that Bobby
Kennedy started.
Is the Children's Health Defense Children's
Defense Fund is in no way affiliated and is
not an anti-vaccine organization.
I got that wrong and I want to correct that.
I heard from Children's Defense Fund, and
I am glad to issue that correction today.
Let's talk about President Joe Biden.
We have such an unusual situation happening
in the 2024 presidential race and particularly
within the Republican primary, that Joe Biden
really needs to do only one thing to win in
2024, and that is to not screw up David screw
up.
That's not very precise language.
What I mean specifically is that Joe Biden
needs to avoid self-inflicted errors and he
will have, I believe, a relatively clear path
to reelection in 2024, despite all of the
criticisms I've had of Joe Biden, despite
concerns among many about his age, if he can
manage not to quote, screw up, I believe that
he is going to get reelected.
Now, you might be thinking, David, that's
very obvious, that how does that count as
any kind of political analysis at this point
in time?
Of course, he shouldn't mess up.
But let me explain why this is so crucial
in this particular situation.
First of all, what about problems that aren't
Joe Biden's doing without ignoring the human
tragedy of crises?
We know from looking at history that often
major crisis events like 911 help the president
in power.
To the extent that George W Bush did not heed
warnings about 911, like we can talk about,
to what degree 911 could be blamed on Bush.
To some degree, that's not what I'm trying
to do today.
But the point is, after 911, the country rallied
around Bush and he had a record high approval
before invading the wrong country and squandering
the approval.
So Joe Biden doesn't have to worry from a
political perspective about tragic events
beyond his control.
He should, of course, work to prevent any
tragedy that that is preventable, without
a doubt.
But we're speaking politically here.
So then you get to the Republican Party.
Biden doesn't have to be amazing to win in
2024.
He has to be better than the alternatives.
He has to be more stable than the alternatives.
And the alternatives are as much of a mess
as I have ever seen.
The Republican Party is in disarray.
There is no coherent vision.
There is no coherent agenda.
You have a party divided between Do we want
more Trump as the MAGA donations or maggots
do?
Or do we realize that Trump has been a disaster
in 2018 and 2020 and 2022?
And we have to go a different way?
Either way, you have a Republican Party that
mostly exists publicly to oppose what Biden
does and say it's all terrible and do anti-woke
culture war nonsense.
Many still loyal to Donald Trump now under
two indictments for classified documents federally.
And then the hush money situation in New York,
possibly more forthcoming indictments.
And then he's running again, despite the fact
that he is not particularly popular nationally,
he is still extraordinarily popular as the
cult leader that he has become among the MAGA
people.
He's actively trying to sabotage any potential
rivals.
And in the meantime, you actually have a pretty
solid Republican candidate by the old standards
of the party in Chris Christie, who is polling
at last check.
Chris Christie is polling.
Where is he?
1.2%.
His big announcement last week got him from
1% to 1.2%.
So Biden can win simply by not messing up.
The economy has to be okay.
And it is.
People have to believe that.
But the economy has to be okay.
And it is he has to be decent.
He has to be stable.
And that's basically what we need from Biden
in order to see him win.
And if you look at recent highly rated general
election polls nationally, you see morning
consult from a few days ago.
You see Biden's leading san.
By three and Biden's leading Trump by two.
These are not blowout numbers at this point
in time, but it is really important to understand
that what's going on in the Republican primary
may dissuade turnout in a way that is not
reflected in the polls and the presence of
Trump as the nominee, who seems like a shoo
in at this point, although we'll see what
happens.
Okay, I'm keeping an open mind.
At this point, Trump seems like a shoo in
if Trump is the nominee.
There is an intangible group of people that
will come out and say, I'm not that engaged
in politics, but we can't have Trump back
again.
And that that is not reflected in the polls
either.
So my sense right now is that Joe Biden, if
he doesn't get in his own way, has a relatively
unobstructed path to reelection.
Whether I love Joe Biden as a candidate is
irrelevant.
You all know that I would like to see a different
candidate.
If it was up to me.
But I am also going to give you analysis that
is based on what we have.
And there is no indication.
I mean, I don't want to be dark, but unless
Joe Biden dies, he's going to be the Democratic
nominee.
I want debates.
I want candidates.
I would love the DNC to hold debates.
They're not going to it's not up to me.
I can't do anything to change that.
That is my sense of this race right now.
And over the next 48 hours, we will see Donald
Trump go to Miami, get arrested, booked, arraigned
once again.
He will then speak from Bedminster tomorrow
night.
We're going to cover all of it and we are
going to see how do the other Republican candidates
react to that?
How does Joe Biden react?
I assume Joe Biden will continue saying absolutely
nothing about it, which I like.
I like that Biden is saying I don't have anything
to do with this.
Independent prosecutors and investigators
are doing what they think they need to do
based on the evidence.
I like Biden staying out of it and governing.
That is the starkest and most productive contrast
that Joe Biden can provide at this point in
time.
Don't screw up.
Could always say that that's what they need
to do.
But it is so particularly important right
now.
Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know if you agree with this assessment.